I went on a internet shopping spree to
find the weirdest ping pong items
possible and today you get to test them
out are you ready and we're already
excited about this okay let's get the
first item
you gotta have it like here you gotta
hit the ball oh wait a second no no you
have to no no no no no you play like
this yeah that's underwhelming and the
art broke it
remember it's a London video there was
the guy who said people are in the pool
this is the toy for that guy it's a
practice too
[Music]
this is the actual this is this is my
theory so you're also guessing you
either have not I've not none of these
things came with instructions you can
get a rally going Otto hits up Emil hits
down but it doesn't like improve you at
all well that's the eyeball eye watching
it does oh now we found the touch
jackpot
it's a device for a ping pong doctor I
can hear his thoughts
he is telling me to hit only passion
from now on that's right I'll give it
one star out of five don't get this one
unless you really know how to use it
because we probably did it for the next
item we will build you a small obstacle
course three two one
it's a ball picker this could be the
first some like truly useful item so
it's human vs machine Ready Set Go
oh
so you lost the ball optimistic ball and
we're done it's not the sturdiest and
it's very shaky yeah it came like loose
this two out of five only two stars well
it lost to the hand do you have your
eyes closed because your nose is close
your ears listen to the sounds and try
and figure out what's going on something
off okay guys you can open your eyes
this is like the the first Michael
O'Connor painting yeah I'm revealing
like a portrait of myself
it's the Rubber wall
buy sticky rubbers feels like a good
build
[Applause]
[Music]
this item is useful yeah
yes come on oh so you're too good
walking yeah let's rate it three and a
half I'd probably give it a four stars
Sally died some challenge for this board
is to give yourself an Around the Net
spot off the board and hitting around
there let's try it out put the ball a
bit more from the middle ml Engineering
in the
yes yes What racket are you using that's
an incredible one
Sensei Rockets perfect for antonettes
how many stars
the rackets are five stars the net is
five stars the balls are fine there's
nothing wrong can't find a single floor
in our products moving on to the next
item it's a battle between us between
you two the item is smoothie machine
okay what's the challenge the robot is
spitting the balls first one to be able
to return the ball back into the track
wins oh nice challenge oh
what's the rating for the little ball
monster it's a simple robot but it's
useful my personal favorite part of this
is too early whirly I'd give it to a
three out of five I would also a three
out of five before we reveal the next
item we have a challenge for you guys we
are launching a new product on pong
Fitness dot store and you get to choose
what it is so whatever you want to see
on pongfinity dot store in the future
leave your ideas below because you can
have an impact
it's two items this is obviously intest
dance this is the item that we're
looking for oh it's not there's a
specific ball for that but should it be
on the on the ground
this item was a stupid idea don't break
it before the challenge begins there
okay sorry the challenge is to create a
20 second table tennis show using these
however you want you want to take some
notes I might do welcome to this magical
table tennis so hosted by your pong okay
please music please
[Music]
oh okay okay I'm not sure what I think
about this part but 20 seconds enough 20
seconds is up
it started off promising due to the
traumatizing ending I'm gonna have to
give this performance a solid four 404.
nice it was actually four out of 20.
time for the next what will it be this
course maybe on the table let's go here
oh this is good the guys are enjoying it
okay
the next challenge is a target shot and
you have to shoot the ball to make it to
spin
I think it's gonna spin like three
seconds three seconds it has to hit like
the top of the uh ball
oh
it's fun one second
oh oh wow
that is very impressive that's like five
seconds should we try it does this thing
actually work if last see you practice
some shots on this and then see if it
affects your forehand Loop show your
normal forehand loops
cool ah
hey
does it feel like you're getting better
yes let's do it okay
[Applause]
that was crazy but then you need to
continue from that you can give the
rating for this this item last one
five times it actually works I've never
seen anything like it this is really
good practice for beginners is this our
new product let us know in the comments
the next item also belongs to the
category try and figure out what on
Earth it is this is the thing I think
they're getting a bit distracted from
the actual task here it has to be with
the spin like like that do you think
they're gonna figure it out no chance
because the actual use makes zero sense
whatsoever I don't think it's the spin
because that makes sense it's a tool for
cleaning the table hey I know when you
glue the rubber if you want a really
uneven
let me show you the correct answer give
me a second I gotta get it set up
it's to get the hip more into the
forehand technique is that a joke no no
this is seriously what I said on the
website to stabilize the core it's not
made for all sizes here
[Music]
[Applause]
it's a tree for a massage zero for elbow
technique we also use just any stick
it is on about two stars
what has me come both from the internet
it can't be another robots your guess is
correct oh yes
I give serves max speed
[Applause]
I have a better challenge for this you
have to come up with a trick shot in net
on the table
[Music]
this challenge might be a bit too easy I
think so too
it's time for the handsome tiger
this one left at least me speechless
it must be used like this you can't
really use spin yeah
to play without spin
I mean you can play with it you are
quite good at it
this is the correct use of the handsome
tiger it makes a nice song too yeah
I might not come with the purchase if
the payment is enough well we have to
compare it with the with the rubber wall
I give this two stars simply because it
doesn't allow you to make spins it's
like a chair without legs
and he broke the first time we tried it